good afternoon I'm Gil Joseph of the
Yale history department and on behalf of
the council of Latin America and Iberian
studies it's my pleasure to welcome you
to this special lecture by the
Nicaraguan writer journalist and
statesman co2 Ramirez Mercado this event
is co-sponsored by the Pointer
fellowship for journalism at Yale and by
the New Haven leon nicaragua sister
cities project which as many of you know
in the not-too-distant future will
celebrate its 25th anniversary the
sister city project has been sponsoring
service delegations and educational
events promoting projects for
sustainable development in the area of
Leon and in general we think improving
relations between the two nations on a
citizen to citizen basis and it's been
doing this since the days of them of the
Nicaraguan Quantrill war back in the
early 1980s throughout that decade
obviously in the process hundreds and
hundreds of new haven errs including an
increasing number of Yale students have
become involved and energized last
summer in fact the project celebrated a
milestone in sending it's a thousandth
delegate from New Haven to Nicaragua
when a high school delegation that i'm
proud to say included our son Matt who's
here with us this afternoon visited and
worked in Lyon quite frankly I can't
think of a better way to showcase the
Latin American councils continuing
collaboration with sister cities than an
afternoon with dr. sara Ramirez sergio
de minas is one of Central America's
most distinguished and best-known
writers in the early phase of his
literary career in the 1960s and 70s his
work was intimately connected with his
own political life and that of his
country The Sunday nista revolution
which ousted the decades-long samosa
family dictatorship in 1979 generated
widespread international solidarity
in the 1970s and 80s the image of young
revolutionaries who were often poets
artists and intellectuals appealed to
many of us in New Haven and throughout
the world and cietila Ramirez was one of
the struggle against samosas most
articulate voices in 1977 while
Secretary General of the Confederation
of Central American Universities he
became head of las doce a group of 12
prominent intellectuals priests and
members of civil society who publix
publicly stated their support for the
Sunday nista front for national
liberation and whose international
diplomatic efforts served to facilitate
the revolutions military triumph over
the dictatorship when the Sun babli came
to power in 1979 dr. Ramirez became part
of the junta of national reconstruction
where he presided over the National
Council of education during these years
of revolutionary reform in addition to
serving as nicaragua's vice president
from 1984 to 1990 he founded the vital
editorial house nueva nicaragua and
along with cultural minister Ernesto
Cardenal supported a new generation of
Nicaraguan writers and intellectuals
although the Sunday nista front lost
power to the uno coalition headed by
violeta chamorro in 1997 Ramirez
continued to serve as the leader of the
Sunday nista block in the national
assembly until 1995 in that year he
founded the movement for Sunday nista
renovation owing to differences he had
on issues of democratic reform with
other sandanista leaders such as the
former and current president of
Nicaragua Daniel Ortega in his personal
memoir of the Sun in Easter Revolution
which is aptly entitled adios muchachos
and which we're going to circulate you
can see it's very well read it's by many
of us that we needed back in in his
memoir and in other writings dr. Ramirez
has become retrospectively critical of
Sandinista
policies that he views as responsible
for churning many Nicaraguans against
the frente sandanista acting on his
beliefs Sofia Ramirez made an
unsuccessful bid for the presidency in
1996 since then while deeply involved in
his nation and Latin America's cultural
and political life as a writer and
columnist he's remained retired from
electoral politics through it all Santa
Ynez has continued to produce his
literary work which has earned him
numerous awards and distinctions by my
count he has published easily over 20
volumes which include novels collections
of short stories and essays and of
course his memoir his latest book only
just published is Tom bored of the
hollow or forgotten drum an essay that
addresses Nicaragua's unique cultural
formation including the nation's
frequently ignored African roots among
dr. Ramirez as many international awards
is the Bruno kreski prize for Human
Rights awarded in Vienna in 1984 the
same year that sister cities here in New
Haven was created he was named Chevalier
a night of arts and letters in Paris in
1993 and he's taught and received
honorary degrees at many distinguished
universities in Latin America Europe and
the United States the theme of his
presentation this afternoon new wins or
old storms contemporary political
changes in Latin America could not be
more timely particularly in light of
recent victories of left and reformist
governments throughout the region the
so-called pink tide that you've been
hearing about and in light of the
sharpening of differences between some
of these governments and the United
States and its regional allies it is a
distinct privilege to welcome eoto to
Ramirez to Yale
thank very much for your kind
presentation thank you for the
university vigil for this invitation to
speak before you this afternoon about
the current situation in Latin America I
would like to say that I always prefer
to speak about literature but in any
case I do my work correctly after the
fall of the Berlin Wall and the
dissolution of the so-called real
socialism the participation of the state
in the economy which was something
inherent to the idea of socialism fell
in total discredit by then no one in the
left they had to speak about plant
economy or state-managed economy solely
we parties lacking a project of the
round couldn't help but to tolerate the
proclamation of the universal panacea of
the market it was the beginning of the
90s we were told the end of the market
economy was equal to democracy in Latin
America we were just coming out of a
long period of military dictatorships
khodadad percent or Saint Dane
revolutions like the one in Ekron we
were entering the end of history at it
was program from the wrong everything
will be counted in terms of the
prosperity produced by a liberal
limitless market the message of radical
liberalism proclaimed that if you were
the restriction to the market economy
the sooner the kingdom of well-being and
full employment would arrive the more
state companies were privatized and more
neutral became the role of the state in
the economy degraded the benefits that
would pull down on the
population employment housing education
and health it was easy to illustrate
this with it with an oil example when
the tie goes up in the bay big ship Bob
but also small ones another old
political a dash of the 19th century
liberalism also reemerge each one should
take care of its part because the whole
takes cares of itself this way the oil
stay worried about the whole should be
put to rest and having to overlie to
worry solely about one spark dreams and
ideals solidarity concern for our
neighbor also went to race or to exile
the truth is that in Latin America no
one had experiences state socialism
inflation blue except through the cyma
cuevas that the Cuban Revolution was
always sending and so on to some extent
through the much more heterodox
experience of the sundanese revolution
in Nicaragua outside those examples the
old revolutionary assumptions of
left-wing parties beginning with land
reform had only very brief for reduce
experimentation space in Bolivia or what
amala during the early 50s change
proclaiming by the left with nothing but
all dreams never fulfilled the voters
armed with hope and patience began to
see that the promises of sint Antonius
well being attributed to the market
worth taking too long privatization of
public corporation became focuses of
corruption and enrichment and the
sacrifices imposed by fiscal and
financial policies only result in the
loss of workstations freezing of wedges
the duration of life conditions and
expansion of the old i beez between rich
and poor impeccable monetary adjustments
but substantial incremental poverty
production foreign debt but growth or
social dead pretty soon the model and
the Bobby
ignore the market economy but the market
society the kingdom was established for
what Pope John Paul the second call
while capitalist we know the building
has been too cheerful the welfare state
was abolished in context with it hadn't
been even existed which meant to
dramatically reduce social expense under
the new credo everything was privatized
even essential services as health and
drinking water the economies of the
Latin American countries were put in I
in a straitjacket and macroeconomic
figures indeed began to change tack
deficits decrease because public
expenditure decrease and inflation was
controlled both the bridge between the
rich who benefit from this measure ease
and the poor who suffer them began to
broaden more and more we increasingly
had Richard rich and poor poor and
democracy didn't generate prosperity has
had been promised so people ended up
getting tired on the other hand
embarrassed contest the old political
systems that were the result of packs
for the melodica stability began to
collapse in Venezuela for example after
the fall of dictator Perez Jimenez the
putt sighing in 1958 between social
democrats and christian democrats
collapse from illness and
ineffectiveness the crisis opened the
door for colonnello chavez could add to
the government of colors on disparities
in 1992 which took failed it won't
Chavez in North prestige to be elected
president in 1998 the bipartisan system
also collapse in Argentina where the
radical party failing absolute discredit
of that the government of death tour de
la rúa failed that entire political and
proceeding a canopic crisis in fact the
giustizia lista parties
actually the only existing party today
and presidential power is dispute among
the Pyrenees divided in different
factions some position more to divide as
that of president meaning other more to
the left as that of the Christian
marriage another traditional system that
weighing in crisis was Costa Rica
president Oscar Arias a Social Democrat
precariously won the election in 2006 as
candidate of the old national liberation
party against a decedent candidate of
the same party Oh Tong Solis opposed to
privatization son to the free trade
treaty with the United States meanwhile
the party that represented the other
half of the system the Christian social
unity collapse after having two former
presidents from that party sentence and
imprisoned for corruption people didn't
want more of the same and saw the old
system going into crisis the political
parties lost credibility and so did the
institution what would was democracy
what ghoul was too late the same people
voters soon realized that they had a
weapon in their hands which was
precisely devote if they had used the
world to let right-wing governments
without any result in their lives they
cool will use it in the other direction
to choose emerging leaders who
questioned the old system what will
happen if they elected those leaders
that were telling the end the opposite
they wonder those that were telling the
ending the liberal system was the cause
of all their ills of their
marginalization of their poverty with
the new century the pendulum have begun
to swing the ball the other end from
right towards left today if we look at
the political map of Latin America we
find only for governments coming from
Rio
party's Mexico Colombia Paraguay and El
Salvador but this group threatens to be
drastically reduce fernando lugo former
bishop of the catholic church in
paraguay who is running as an emerging
candidate from the left is leading the
service his victory would mean the end
of the reign of the Colorado party in
power for almost 70 years and the FMA n
the old Marcy to guerrilla transformed
into a political party in El Salvador
also has an strong possibilities to win
depreciate presidential elections
against arena furthermore for the first
time in Central America we will have
governments from Guatemala to Panama
that wouldn't be from the right a
radical change for countries long ago
depicted as banana republics no one in
Europe will find it rate in a giving
moment electoral wave is stripped away
right-wing governments borders always
reward success and punish failure this
is a goal but not enough reason to
explain the changes among us certainly
the conscience facture determined by
political culture is far from being the
same in both continents so all promises
wore out and now the live is in the
presidential palaces but which left
there are left leaders in power it is
true but that doesn't mean they belong
to a more genius political landscape
throughout the map the territory of the
left doesn't have the same color label
leaders indigenous leaders all guerrilla
fighters military rebels bishops who
drop their castle a respectable the
politician woman an oncologist
why are they there white or what junai
them and what device then let's take a
look at the model couva in the first
place with the traditional leading his
regime that will soon complete halfa
century is the only country with that
the state economy and one party system
in the continent dang populist
governments in different grades with an
aunt imperialists anti-capitalist speech
that intend to replace the traditional
political structures in Venezuela
Ecuador Nicaragua and Bolivia
governments of Social Democratic sighing
with the socialist program market market
by pramit ism in Brazil Argentina Chile
and away social democratic governments
which range from Center to left in
Dominican Republic Peru Costa Rica
Panama Honduras and Guatemala whoever
one cannot imagine a block of less wing
countries in Latin America on the red
unique social socialist ideology life
for example the Soviet field until the
end of the Cold War when there were
state status with a uniform structure
and behavior in East Europe we are far
far from that but there are alignments
between then the most apparent being
that of the country's the form Alba the
Bolivarian alliance led by President
Chavez unintegrated by Venezuela q
Ecuador Bolivia and Nicaragua it is a
blog that has declared political profile
cooperation mechanisms based on oil
supply from Venezuela to his partners
and the intention of integrating a
military alliance in which the conflict
with colombia is a very important factor
this conflict has a decisive geo
political influence in Latin
the left is gorillas in Columbia have
been around for half a century they are
a real army with the proportion of
irregular Regular Force and they
dominate an extensive wild territory
bordering with Venezuela and Ecuador the
oil romantic aura has been darkened by
the holding in drug traffic where they
obtain considerable resources and their
presence in the territory of Venezuela
Ecuador where they obtain supplies and
established resting camps create
periodic crisis like the one that rose
if you do a weeks ago colombia troops
assaulted a guerilla camping it in
Ecuadorian territory killing a guerrilla
leader and causing these severance of
diplomatic ties with Ecuador Venezuela
and Nicaragua with Colombia Nicaragua
also has a conflict concerning my
marriage my boundaries with Colombia but
let's let us we talk return to Chavez to
the Chavez blog
chaves uses oil supply on concessional
terms seeking for alliances beyond the
Alba limits this way beside the
concessional oil agreements with Bolivia
Ecuador Cuba Nicaragua he also grants
cheap oil through why honduras Dominican
Republic and Guatemala and to El
Salvador through in El Salvador the
municipal councils controlled by the
fmln the generals loans dear nations the
support nocturnal dead redemption has
was done with Argentina as well as the
creation of the banco del Sur and the
gas dogged the Lodox stem from Orinoco
to rio de la plata are also instrument
destined to consolidate Chavez political
leadership expand it dejong its
frontiers on the other hand there are
presidents in the map who identify with
irresponsible socialism of President
Lula which G gives him kind of a
continental leadership but this doesn't
mean there is a block of countries
around Brazil as Alba around Venezuela
it is a matter of identities these
presidents like al baraka long in
Guatemala or candidate Lugo in Paraguay
have stated some sort of choice the
pragmatist of Lula instead of Chavez
radical plethoric Lula comes from labor
files a metallurgist union leader he has
one prestige as a statement that puts
economic growth and democratic stability
ball ideological portals anyway
brazilian economic power in all sense
less volatile than venezuela and more
reliable as as a long-term partner
partner for other Latin American
countries also lula differs from Chavez
in their scope of energy policies while
for Chavez oil is the axis of his
international influence
Loula is looking for partners in Latin
America to produce biofuel based on
agriculture mainly sugarcane and here
the head of ideology jumps to Fidel
Castro Chavez on ortega transforming
food into fuel is a crime against
humanity and the perpetrator of this
crime is his socialist the album
populist blog could not be explained
without the leadership of President
Chavez in one other sense the fate of
the government that form it is bound to
Chavez own fate who has the key to oil
which is the main if not the only factor
of croatian of this alliance this allows
he lies to exercise a super g'nite
populism lie Nicaragua where presidents
Ortega capacity to give subsides called
pigs poultry and building materials to
people in need the paint on the open
hunt of Chavez but at the same time in
such a small economy as nicaragua's this
stream of subsidies and donation is like
poison candy because it causes inflation
Ortega can use the money he will see
from selling the oil subsidized by
Chavez to gas station local gas station
to finance his social programs but he
cannot lower the fuel prices to consumer
because is also inflationary Chavez
cannot allow it because the organization
of countries that produce oil doesn't
allow him so operating and living costs
continues to rising in karama in spite
of Chavez oil and in spite of the
populists speech if one day
international oil prices fell or Chavez
cool not control the growing turbulences
in the witness fellow economy inflation
lack of supplies these Alliance will
hopelessly hopelessly dissolve the fact
that he already lost the plate
sit for a radical constitutional reform
last year is a warning of the political
precariousness of this regime and
therefore of the political
precariousness of his alliances so I'm
on the Left governing in Latin America
not only their identities count or the
color area in the map not only comes the
waiting which they are aligned but also
other type of interest economic
interests border interest which country
rich and which countries are poor who
extend the hunt to give and who extend
it to demand well class of all or new
border conflicts there are among those
countries and even the territorial size
of each one Brazil has a visible
presence in South America it changed
borders with practically all southern
countries and sells his product to all
of them it also is the change economic
of the world and no one can ignore this
weight when evo morales decide to
national I the gas deposits in Bolivia
Brazil was the most affected Petrobras
which is a Brazilian state-owned company
was one of the biggest foreign
concession Ares for the exploitation of
bolivian gasps how shoe Lola respond to
this measure as proceeding of a regional
superpower that see its economic
interests affected or as a socialist
president who understand the nationalist
demands of another socialist president
at the moment Bolivia was a poor country
rotting in front of a rich country those
are the differences in the specific ways
that can not be obviated when or why
decide to set up a cellulose plank in
its marking of the river or why
argentina reacted again against is
alleging environmental damages
argentina is Anna strong power well why
has no power at all he has been so since
both countries which had a common
history decide to follow up separate
roads in this conflict guru why has seen
itself at this small country that had
the right to seek development through
Transcendental investments the cellulose
plant was first visit topping
argentinian side according to the
Uruguayan allegation and then there were
no objections this matter is still in
dispute in international tribunals what
it is a clash between the argentine of
the cuteness mirage who are declared
socialist and the uruguay of president
of array Vasquez the oncologist also a
declared socialist so where those
ideological identity stunts which is the
weight of political affinity I could
give all the examples that mark the
differences and contradiction among
Latin American left-wing governments but
for me one is the most important and the
most decisive Democratic will is that
simple whether left win leaders once
reaching the presidency pretend to stay
or accept all turn ability in power as a
role simple but crucial because it marks
the frontier between the magnetic wheel
I authoritarian wheel and that makes the
difference I'll turn ability or
indefinite r election they are to clear
and different roles to the left in
Brazil again lula is heading toward the
eng of his second mandate on until now
he says until now he says he will not
seek a third he called pure folly the
proposal of some the proposal of song
influential party sample of his to wrong
again as candidate on the other hand a
key reform to the constitution of
venezuela that Chavez submitted
two popular consultation was indefinite
to election he lost the place visit and
that possibility is closed for the time
being as he said which means that he
will tie it again before the place
visiting of Venezuela when they ask Lula
what he thought of the indefinite
relation proposed by Chavez he responded
I quote I can only speak for Brazil a
knife in Brazil cannot play with the
sinkhole democracy it took us a long
time and a lot of people suffer to
consolidate it end of the quote he was
just remembering remembering the Brazil
has suffered 20-year military
dictatorship between 1960 for our 1985
and before that the dictatorship of a
popular leader Ditullio Baracus that
made similar promises as chaves that is
not the greatest reference for a
continent that in the past underwent
dictatorship as a course of history
dictatorships in brazil in argentina
uruguay in venezuela in nicaragua in
colombia in bolivia in the Dominican
Republic in Cuba in Argentina and Chile
in Guatemala generally supported by
successive administration of the United
States once in Managua during the first
congress of the sunday news front back
in the 90s i heard lula say in a speech
that the grey mistake of the left have
been to create an ideological difference
between bourgeois democracy and
proletarian democracy when truly there
was only one class of democracy in doing
so the left had acquired a bad prestige
being presented as an enemy to democracy
which means to voting and choosing your
rollers those are wars I never forgot
and for me it marks the great difference
among the leaders of the Latin American
left in power today those who think the
democracy that I love salterne ability
in power is an outdated system are still
thinking in terms of bourgeois democracy
and thinking that by taking advantage
this divulge our democracy of the
bourgeois democracy mechanisms some sort
of proletarian democracy can't be built
then they are looking toward the past
the speaker stripping institution on
establishing a new system that should
arrive from the ashes of the old system
but in that new system the leader Orca
do as we say in Latin America should
remain where he is because he is judge
in this principle I in order to do so it
needs a constitution that the love scene
to be reelected as many times as deemed
to be necessary or as many times as he
wants this is not the new system it is
the same one we have record only live
with since the 19th century a source of
bad habits corruption confrontation
violence and poverty again wearing wrong
of the irrepressible leader the
enlightened who knows who what the
country needs the replaceable
irreplaceable leader is not precisely
Jose and all idea of the left it comes
from the darkest bottom of Latin
American history from the deepest abyss
of patriarchal society where the lung
owner became the military leader and
then the perpetual president what we
need in modern democracy with citizens
having the right to choose an eternity
in government real democracy of all
times that do not reject those say
individuals freedom proclaiming the
Constitution born with independence in
the nineteen 19th century which have
always been so unpleasant for
dictatorship of
all times today authoritarian socialism
or populism speak of revolutionary
thoughts that cannot be challenged and
before such declaration press freedom
and freedom of speech suffer a lot and
so we go back to the time of absolute
truth that by some coincidence always
going to be official truth power cleans
the closet right to reason and truth
property to decide what is fair for
public information fair unhealthy what
is harmful for the political order what
is not and when it isn't it is
registered as a part of this conspiracy
to undermine power power declared itself
incompatible with tolerance in front of
other people thought and therefore
decides to prevent other people thought
to be expressive a state philosophy is
reviving which seeks to be expressive
through constitutional warrants and
specific lobes in which freedom of
speech should be regulated that is to
say is subjected on behalf of a huddle
of reasons always a lead for the old
right under military arms is worth for
national reasons for national excuse me
security reasons for authoritarian
socialists it is for the interests of
the large popular majorities once
reaching government the leaders of the
authoritarian life intended to be
related with our limit to lead the
construction of the political model it
is what Chavez in our a test and then
find followers in other countries but
reality modifies always intentions
we must take into consideration that
political projects with a messianic
character always need grey consents in
Venezuela Bolivia or Nicaragua the
emerging leaders who once total power
have the support of a substantial part
of the population but not of all the
population it is a strong support but
not the majority and in front of radical
proposal polarizations happens that is
the reason why Chavez lost the prevacid
to change the constitution in Venezuela
in Bolivia the new constitution proposed
by Evo Morales has created
confrontations that even threaten
domestic territorial integrity and the
new constitution is still pending to be
ratified by a pleb asset in Nicaragua no
matter how much she wants to stay in the
presidency the nil Ortega knows that he
was elected by Harley thirty-eight
percent of the world and he doesn't have
the consent to radically change the
constitution and remove the obstacle of
non reelection we also need to remember
that changes in power in those countries
have taken place through boating and no
fluke weapons that established some
severe limits to proposal for radical
changes revolutions want to be a source
of right and use their power while it
still lacks institutional forms to
change everything without consulting
anyone but it is an our power which
created its own legality now changes
must go through legal consultation
processes and therefore the voice of the
citizens most be heard institutional
mechanisms cannot be obviated either no
matter how subject to manipulation they
might be the constitutional reforms that
would allow Chavez to stay in the
presidency until death were frozen body
lies by last year's
prevacid the original proposal proposal
in the new constitution of Olivia was
indefinite election but it takes a pro
last year but by the Constituent
Assembly states that President Evo
Morales can only do it once in Ecuador
the original proposal was also
indefinite relation but President Rafael
Correa has the clear now that the
relation should be I quote one single
time because we sincerely believe that
democracy is all turn ability the
changes in those intentions whether
force or not are advances to a common
idea of democracy in Latin America in
Nicaragua the Constitution dosing a low
continuous relation but in order to stay
president Ortega is determined to reform
it or create a parliamentary regime that
allows him to act as a First Minister
with a decorative president but these
straps are too visible in if the
election took place today according to
the surveys Ortega would loss by sixty
percent of the world there is a las
substantial question what is the scope
for economic and social change to what
extent can radical rhetoric become a
reality in the lives of the poor are we
witnessing a true revolutionary
transformation of the property system
and distribution of wealth the proposal
for the state to lead the economy and
even intervening it continues to be done
proposal and song of the left
governments does don't keeping their to
rise it the state can no longer
intervene radically to distribute these
surpluses of the economy among the
poorest without perturbing
macro-economic balances and without
upsetting the international
financial organisms the left can not
intervene private companies or multi
national capital banks the simply fret
of doing so creates alarm on a large
drives away foreign investors all this
means that the left also lives in a real
war which is which is now a global war
from which it can hardly escape it
cannot escape from the free trade
treaties or free market associations or
patting and brand treaties and that
reality far from the flamming
revolutionary rhetoric tell us the DCCC
left the government's in most cases poor
countries that cannot survive by dense
Elvis they must end to sustain economic
growth amid the dollar crisis and the
crisis of financial markets that come
from the United States and the cost
constant rises in oil prices which come
from Venezuela a great paradox this last
one the left that used to demonize
social democracy like hung adulterated
variant of capitalist exploitation can
not go beyond a project of reform and
market economy in search of benefit in
the poorest some of the new left leaders
in government are talking of political
structural changes that have to do with
political power but few of them are
speaking of economic structural changes
to transform the economic structure of
the hotel countries my generation
laughed at our parents wisdom who wanted
to moderate our radical fur ball
remembering us a parent remember that in
order to distribute wealth you first
need to create it
today very few laughs at that advice and
no left-wing ruler denies that in order
to have any well to distribute fiscal
discipline is necessary and investment
is necessary and that the worst enemy to
the police income is inflation maybe
that moderation doesn't fit in the head
of those who want abundant resources to
spend with they think are endless and
those can be infinitely wasted but that
is an illusion I am NOT speaking of wool
or bar intentions I assume that populace
is based on one phone on wool feelings
and solely on solidarity on the desire
to favor those who have little or
nothing but that Google will cannot hell
having disastrous consequences which
roamed which turn against those in one's
to favor neither candy left offer a
magento solution to the different
countries of Latin America where it has
reached power since the weight of
heterogeneity is overwhelming having
four neighboring countries Chavez speech
can resemble a load that of Mo Morales
and both the speeches in the rhetoric
resembled that of Fidel Castro but of
all of them only Chavez can carry out
expensive populist experiments because
he is the only one that has the oil
sources permanently open anyway
primanti's always take takes his share
Chavez nationalized foreign companies
but he pays ding at market prices to
avoid being exposed to international
reprisals and o'keefe written to cut oil
supplies to the right united state he
will never dare to do so because he know
it would be suicidal evo morales interim
carry out the jaws nationalization of
the gas reserve a space on a pragmatic
understanding with exploit concession of
nerd
and he knows the sharp its international
problem for Bolivia is the claim for an
exit to the sea which has which he has
to resolve with Chile where there is
another left government both of a very
different natural however is something
unite the multicolored left map of these
governments is the heap of contradiction
with the United States some more visible
and more evident than others I need to
solve it that the united state doesn't
have any hemispheric policy except for
the application of all prejudice cannon
that only facilitates confrontation and
those which come from the ambition of
having bilateral free trade treaties
which each Latin American country
without giving in any substantial way in
this protectionist privileges and also
of course policies to combat roles which
represent high costs for the Latin
American countries and policies to
combat terrorism share without strain
one of those all prejudice and confuse
Kanaan is that of the migratory policies
which is even more darking in times of
lecturer campaigning in the United
States behavior before the immigrants is
always subject to judgment in Latin
America because it affects millions
those who come over here and those who
stay there and it will continue to be a
point of friction until trollee fair
solution are applied Delhi will continue
to be left wing governments in Latin
America elect by the citizen my
aspiration is that when voters are
deceived by Deng they remove them with
their vote as they remove the right-wing
governments that failed but I wish even
more that left-wing government succeed
in favor in the poorest and in creating
societies where equity and justice
strange when it comes to distribution of
wealth but this only be
achieve if we devote our selfish to
democracy and stay away from up
territorialism furthermore i think that
i left that moved away from democracy
ceased to research because it lost its
identity and is assimilated by the OL
authoritarian right after italian ism
those have a single color the left has
the challenge to seek solutions to the
precarious life conditions of the
poorest no matter how difficult the task
might be because it its essence resides
in that but it should do it far from
populism I'm not less important it is is
its performance in the exercise exercise
of power from far from corruption
practices so Abbott role in Latin
America when a democratic system works
it can investigate and demand
accountability to those who govern for
that reason after Italian is also
embodies another danger the lack of
transparency who in all power is in a
single fist even if it is a left fist it
is easier for illicit fortunes to rise
and for those who proclaim the reventon
of the poor to be comped rich overnight
I have witness such cases people hope
for things to change but to change
mainly in the ethical dimension in these
and in many other senses the left needs
to demonstrate that it is different and
that it is faithful to his principal
among which moral integrity and
democracy can not be absent
thank you doctor tremendously ambitious
and run ranging talk I'm sure people
have questions and comments we would
like to open the floor is in it but we'd
like to remind everyone that even though
our main space has been preempted
outside yeah we do have we do invite you
all to a small reception in this room
after the question and answer period for
dr. Sara Jimenez and his wife was with
us get through these gadelle my otter
god so we're so the floor is open nice
hear your take on pimp on your own
I will ready to something as if I catch
you representation I did not intellect
was in general understood scholars or
artists or writers have played an
important role in that American history
in the last 50 or more years and I think
that many of them in some sense have
been involved in supporting the kind of
revolution that you criticized were
recently Malaga dosa has me that can
produce easement I think that his
criticism is a very easy because it
almost easily but they got to conserve
am you conservative policing that things
that politics in general is bad and that
we shouldn't have a corrective action
why would I would like to know European
our we should be water intellect was
broadly understood to play now they seem
that America whether you think that they
can likely to be adopted by the
intellectually later on well I remember
that when I started to write I consider
myself an intellectual of principles an
intellectual committed we say then but
when we say the committed we knew what
we were talking about we welcome it with
the left and there was only one kind or
left the left that supported the Cuban
Revolution they left that supported
changes revolutionary changes in Latin
America the left that was in struggle
against imperialism capitalism and so on
but after the fall of the Berlin whoa in
at the beginning of the 90s the night is
dose those truths didn't were so solid
anymore and there was a split amidst the
ranks of the of the left and there were
a lot of criticism against what was then
call for the priest dying real socialism
we didn't college real socialists before
it was simple socialism then now it is
difficult to to to identify this solid
array of principles for which the left
was fighting before the the aim of the
real socialist it is very difficult now
to to find this is so this one single
ideology or a single foreign poll for
the left to see things nowadays
and then a different new phenomenon
arise to in the 70s in the 60s to
someone that proclaim himself to be from
the right it was something didn't exist
because everyone was ashamed to to be
identified to be from the intellectual
from the right there were no principle
of the right now there are intellectual
that exposed and selfish as defenders of
the right like mario lega joseph for
example from the poor al burro know
which proclaimed the defense source of
liberalism in plain terms now this is
the reason why i said i think has
changed a lot nowadays but the question
is which is left what is left and it is
the thing i am trying to explain my
paper perhapses if link left with epic
principles we can find in the we can
find the north where where where we are
seeking
yeah in the past people were fighting
against the authoritarian regimes on the
right the arts played a very large role
in and he wrote a lot of fictional
pieces and opportunities of that and
there's there's poetry and user not
things along those lines have you seen
anything like that happening now against
the greasing authoritarianism on the
left in places like Nicaragua and yeah
yeah I think that literally Nicaragua
about the revolution there is any is
there is any sort of such literature
written in the 80s I will say by now
jungle right there tends to be very
critical with the revolution with the
traditional conception or revolution I'm
very critical with what is happening
today in name in the name of revolution
and then I i think that when we in the
future talk about literature of the
revolution it is going to be very very
critic one of the new writer new
generation that are going to expose
revolution is a scene that was very far
from ideals from the ideal get proclaim
in accordance with the behavior of the
leaders of that of that revolution that
is my idea of the audio literature of
the revolution acara when the future yes
please very much appreciated your broad
approach and your analytic
Oh positions of current president's in
Latin America I'd like to ask you from
your ethical and let me perspective what
do you think of the president that
Fujimori is the first ex president of a
country who is being tried in his own
country what kind of presage for future
democratization ethical adjustment for
you know future Democratic presidents
well I think for one is not really the
first president to be George because of
corruption a president are not banging
in Nicaragua for example was George
before before for amore and convenient
to 20 years in prison but now aleman is
free free because of the because of his
agreements with daniel ortega and he is
he is free because he was a considerable
it to denarian by the judges and then
was sent to his house and then he was
allowed to to be free in the city of
Managua ending and now he is a lot with
3 in the whole country he has the quanta
4444 jail thing is a presidential run of
what mullah the way Jose because of
corrosion aborting absence because he
was a refugee ated in panama and again
president of what amala the last
president not the last one of the last
president what amala who is living in
mexico in he was also judged because of
corruption and so on what I i think the
the the the trial against for your money
of course is very very very important I
think they I think is the citizens want
to see if the law is applied against
powerful people this is
it's n dental thing in Latin America if
the lower the law is only applying case
of poor people that commit some kind of
robbery and so on or powerful and rich
people who'll be brought to justice to
then this disease reason why it is for
me this trial very very important well I
think the this question in Latin America
now I'm its environmentalist is if I'm
politician to economic economists to if
is if the production of fuel oil a of
fuel it should be from corn or from
sugarcane and apparently it to produce
fuel from sugar king is more illicit
than produce it from corn I'm in any
kawa even when proceeding or Terry
supposing the production of fuel from
from any kind of agricultural product
there is a lot of fuel being produced
from sugarcane and exported to the
United States
I found it very interesting in your
presentation that you've really helped
the formula that model speak to the fire
in terms of contradictions
destabilization zand pilation airy
trends I'm just wondering you know if we
look at the other side of this obviously
in terms of free trade agreements in
terms of a free trade area or existing
free trade like cop not I'd like to hear
you talk a little bit about that there's
been so much disaffection not only in
Mexico and Central America but also in
this country if we think about the
recent primary debates workers losing
jobs in places like Mexico and Central
America where you have really don't have
an equal playing field where there are
huge subsidies given to big agribusiness
producers where you don't have the
subsidies of local producers we're often
the kind of investment comes into mikyla
jobs that leave a lot to be desired and
often then are taken away from workers
and sent to Ava anyway and we're in a
place like Nicaragua it seems that in
Ortega and many Sandinistas are becoming
despite their left rhetoric they're
becoming real estate entrepreneurs in
places like San Juan del school in this
new moment so putting yourself in the
position of Costa Rica or corny god I've
walked how do you attempt to negotiate
capitalism
integration with a more human face that
really does help workers and peasants
and the poor people in that area Nina
you may be increasing wealth but what
kind of wealth and with what ultimate
consequences hmm well I think a free
trade treaty they say it's a scene for a
pleaded control any girl I want a
difference in like a country for a
country like Mexico that have boarded
with the United States a very big
country within millions of people
affected by this free trade with the
United States there are many protests
you you can see it every day in the
papers because it really affect the
economic life of all for such a country
like like Mexico in Nicaragua which is a
very very tiny economy I think the
people is in some kind of concrete
benefits out of the treaty this free
treaty with the United States textile
for example the reason is a very
important quarter of million jars a for
Nicaragua the sport of textile to the
United States this is a and you can feel
it in the indie development in the real
behavior of economy today in Nicaragua a
big issues like protectionism for
example affect more Mexico than the
danica what that is a very dependent
economy with or without a free-trade DVD
with united state and I think a the
treaty between you and the United States
could have been
negotiated better in more juice term
that the tenancy it was negotiated but
in i think the negative consequences are
going to be seeing individual because
this treaty has times that wrong out for
example in some moment all the decor
danica day that that the United Stated
to export the Nicaragua will enter
nicaragua in the future for example it
is going to be disastrous for for for
corn producer Nicaragua which are barely
a little peasant that produce quorum but
on the other side the the the Alba
agreement with Venezuela it is Italy
panacea for for Nicaragua because let's
see Nicaragua is importing all the the
oil from from Venezuela just now 10
million barrels of oil on Chavez is
giving a credit to the to Nicaragua I
think twenty-five thirty percent of the
of this oil bill which represent three
hundred million dollars in credits for
the country but it is not going no it is
not going to the central budget budget
of the country but to a private company
organized between vertigo and carrots
and this money is is a indie merging at
the merging of the public expenditure in
the in the country this country is
called Albin eek it has a shades of some
people related to ortega and shares of
some people related to to Java and they
decide how to spend this money this
enormous amount of money for such a
controller Nicaragua
take into account that Nicaragua
sporting per year some 1 billion and
three hundred million dollars something
like that and from the Alba dreaming we
are receiving four hundred million
dollars a quarter of all our sports to
be explained freely by Ortega decisions
or what Ortega decide without going into
the the the channels of the central
budget it is criminal for it so a little
controller Nicaragua and then or telecon
is paying it does he like it can give
his thin rose for people poultry he
can't decide to 22 villeroy when he
decides out of the budget outward of
what is or what it is prowling in the
budget and this is the reason why I was
saying that it is inflationary this kind
of predator is absolutely a negative 44
44 the country and it is the pattern of
the HIV is going to use also in El
Salvador if the FMLN wink elections
because all the oil supplies are going
to come from Venezuela to El Salvador
thank you very much okay thank you